here we see president clinton looking
for something anything to hug besides
his wife
it was announced that
creed singer scott stapp will play frank
sinatra in an upcoming movie but the
good news is sammy davis jr will be
played by scarlett johansson
last week on larry king live marlon
brando made the shocking statement that
hollywood is quote run by jews
in response outraged jewish
organizations made it snow in new york
in april
[Applause]
well tennis player ophthalmologist
transsexual dr renee richards is writing
a book about her life it is tentatively
titled tennis without balls
well this coming monday is oscar night
and three films the english patient
secrets and lies and shine are locked in
a tight race in the category best
picture there's not a chance in hell i
will ever see
the co-founder of the waffle house
passed away this week at the age of 97.
he died the way so many waffle house
patrons have a knife fight in the
parking lot
a sad piece of news came in today from
the bedford hills prison where gene
harris is serving a sentence of 15 years
at noon yesterday she made her second
suicide attempt two cellmates three
wardens and a priest were killed
real estate mogul donald trump announced
this week that after three and a half
years of marriage he is seeking a
divorce from wife marla maples according
to trump maples violated part of their
marriage agreement when she decided to
turn 30
unacceptable
the bat used by babe ruth to hit his
500th home run was auctioned off this
week also i'll be auctioning off the bat
i use to keep my neighborhood white
the pentagon announced yesterday that
u.s and british planes had struck iraqi
air defense sites south of baghdad
defense officials say the president
wanted to send a clear message to the
iraqi government that he knows exactly
where iraq is
who are safer drivers men or women well
according to a new survey 55 percent of
adults feel that women are most
responsible for minor fender benders
while 78 blame men for most fatal
crashes please note that the percentages
in these pie graphs do not add up to 100
percent because the math was done by a
woman
for those of you hissing at that joke it
should be noted that that joke was
written by a woman so
now you don't know what the hell to do
it
[Applause]
no i'm just kidding we don't hire women
well a new report ranks the new york
city subway system as the best in the
country
this was according to masturbating hobo
monthly
in an interview this month matthew
mcconaughey said that he wants to die
the same way his father did right after
having sex mcconaughey's mother has said
absolutely not
warner brothers is producing a new movie
in which superman is black and a black
superman actually makes a lot of sense
when you remember that superman was
abandoned by his parents as a baby
pop singer madonna was outraged this
week when a tabloid photographer snapped
her picture while she was breastfeeding
her new baby apparently the baby was
blocking her nipple
warner brothers is producing a new movie
in which superman is black in this
version black superman's kryptonite is
an honest day's work
a new trend on the internet is photos of
people planking which is the act of
lying face down keeping one's body stiff
while balancing on top of something or
what protestants call sex
[Music]
apple has announced that it will add
hundreds of new emojis to its ios system
including a person at a spa a vomiting
face and a shushing finger finally
giving emoji fans the ability to
describe what it was like to work for
harvey weinstein
hollywood prostitute devine brown has
written a book describing in lurid
detail exactly what she did with hugh
grant the book sells for twenty five
dollars but for thirty five dollars
she'll show you
[Applause]
a family in australia has discovered
what is believed to be the world's
oldest message in a bottle which was
thrown into the sea over 130 years ago
by a then middle-aged bernie sanders
after closing out a successful first
season the wnba is considering several
changes to improve the level of play in
the league next year among the proposals
extending the playoffs increasing
salaries bringing back the three-point
line and replacing all the female
players with guides
how is no one keeping track of how many
guns people own there is a real law in
texas that says it's illegal to own more
than six dildos and i get why no one
needs that many
if you have more than six dildos it's a
clear sign you are training for
something awful
thanks i'm norm mcdonald and now the
fake news well it is finally official
murder is legal in the state of
california
[Applause]
testimony during the final week provided
some spell binding moments
in a brilliant move during closing
arguments
simpson attorney johnny cochran put on
the knit cap prosecutors say oj war the
night he committed the murders although
o.j may have hurt his case when he
suddenly blurted out hey hey easy with
that that's my lucky stabbing hat
a new poll shows that hillary clinton's
poll numbers have dropped two points
since she made her presidential campaign
official because for some reason once a
woman makes it official we suddenly
start to lose interest
oprah winfrey's longtime boyfriend
stedman graham has written a new book
called you can make it happen a nine
step plan for success step number one
become oprah winfrey's boyfriend
[Applause]
[Music]
then the other aider just hang around
it was reported that yahoo and aol will
combine to form a new company because no
one wants to die alone
is the first lady a compulsive liar
though it's beginning to look that way
in an interview on last night's 2020
intended to promote her new book it
takes a village mrs clinton folded under
tough questioning by barbara walters and
admitted that in fact it does not take a
village
and furthermore that she was aware that
it does not take a village when she
wrote the damn book
[Applause]